we are ready for our first surprise
guest and i'm going to give you some
clues okay
let's see how you would do he would be
on your top 10 list of guests i think
you'd want at any party
you once surprised him on his birthday
oh my god and his stupid human trick
david being
one of the greatest television hosts of
all time
do you know who this might be i know
exactly who it is
who is it david letterman let us welcome
david letterman hi dave
everybody hi drew
happy birthday savannah hello how are
you hi
she's dying she can't believe it oh my
gosh
i'm having a great time catching my
breath i can hear you
dave i can't i can't hear her
oh sh is there a filter oh wait do you
have a filter on
i can't tell her to unmute can you hear
me
are you zooming dave what's like yeah
are you good at technology i'm not a cat
that is everywhere i'm sorry i can't
hear her oh you look like a fine can you
hear me
okay it's the thought that counts yeah
we can hear you we hear you
can you hear us we get it
forget that can you believe i mean
that's so sweet of him to do that
i know when was the last time you
actually saw it i feel the same way he
does about zoom
yeah especially when my daughters crash
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what do you think dear sit down
oh my i'm
gonna need the tissues yeah i'm so
grateful that you came here
let me tell you something you know that
uh little trick with the computer
and stuff that zoomer thing that was my
idea that was good you still got it oh
thank you
it was really effective i i really
thought i was like okay yeah you know
dave
i get it too um no are you you're
actually crying
oh that breaks my heart god bless you
i'm i'm i'm so grateful that you are
showing up
well i i i can't i can't thank you
enough for everything
and the friendship that you demonstrated
for us when we were uh on the show and
it meant a great deal then
and this means a great deal as well
happy happy birthday and thank you
thank you for or did i invite myself i
don't know how this happened
you're this you're kind of the guest of
honor next to drew but wait wait
four years actually crying she's crying
she's shocked
i told her she really thought she might
know it i love you i love you as well
okay wait hold on because we want to
hear everything we want to hear all of
your stories we have to take a break
okay we stick with us
do i go back to the zoo stay right here
we're gonna have a lot more with drew
and dave
when we come back